if you're looking for an excuse to
return to The Witcher 3
it sounds like blood and wine might just
be it CD Projekt RED second and final
expansion takes place in the colorful
region of Tucson a Duchy untouched by
war southeast of tameria in the land of
anger 'n for those of us who skipped out
on oxenfurt geography class all you need
to know is that it's a new region
southeast of novigrad and it kind of
looks like a mediterranean countryside
this new region is roughly the size of
no man's land or novigrad and it's known
for its wine warm weather and wealth so
how you be spending time in Tucson well
the expansion adds 90 new quests a
hundred new pieces of armor some of
which include Witcher sets more than 30
new weapons a redesigned user interface
new mutations and a vineyard to relax in
gerelds name this should keep you busy
for around 20 to 30 hours oh and in case
you were interested there is a new
Skellig egwin deck if you don't have the
season pass you can get all this for 20
bucks when it launches but when does it
launch CD Projekt RED hadn't given an
exact date when they stopped by the
office but they sounded pretty confident
that it would drop either in May or June
from what I could tell during my
three-hour hands on preview blood and
wine takes place after the main story or
right before some of the final quests in
Wild Hunt just like hearts of stone if
you haven't finished the main game or if
you aren't a high enough level you will
have the option to start a new adventure
at the beginning of blood and wine can't
get used to the way you Knights talk
especially how you switch back and forth
between flowery and well there's
normally my first steps into salt
brought back memories of being washed
ashore and Skellig afore the first time
what's striking about this new region is
that you won't stumble across bloody
battlefields and people ready to take up
a side in the war in fact a lot of the
inhabitants seem to have their head in
the clouds ignoring what's really
happening in the continent and can you
blame them Toussaint's rolling green
hills colorful vegetation and warm skies
are a sight to see but it isn't just a
pretty picture dotted with more question
marks and exclamation points it felt
like a new world that's been around way
before it was created in the books or
when CD Projekt RED started designing it
the characters have a different accent
the armour and clothing looks nothing
like what I saw in temeria and the
landscape was entirely new in fact the
developer
that guided me through the preview said
many of the assets used in blood and
wine were created from scratch just like
the main game it's this detail that
pulled me right in you I do not know sir
nor seem you a knight yet still I'm
profoundly grateful nay indebted to you
for your succor
this trophy sir is yours but if this
setting caught my interest and it's the
characters that demanded it a year later
The Witcher threes engine still holds up
nicely but it's worth noting that I did
play this on PC the facial animations
are convincing the voice acting is as
good as you've come to expect and the
writing is still top-notch like hearts
of stone some of the best moments are
when Geralt felt like a fish out of
water for instance in one quest Geralt
must crash a festival in order to track
down a killer to find the killer he
needs to remove a ribbon from a horse
dress up his unicorn and find a golden
fish in a lake normally you'd have to
sneak up on the horse and actually fish
for the golden fish but time is of the
essence using signs in his Witcher
senses Geralt cheats his way to the end
I couldn't help but grin as girl
awkwardly tried to justify his behavior
to pissed off citizens blood and wine is
still dark and very gory but this
lighter tone lets the characters really
shine but talking and sunbathing isn't
all you'll be doing in blood and wine
you're still a Witcher and that means
you'll be slang plenty of monsters in
the three hours I played I fought four
bosses some were pretty standard sign
block parry attack but one in particular
forced me to change up my playstyle
simple blocks and attacks were useless
if you've played a Zelda game of two you
probably won't have much trouble
figuring out this bosses weaknesses but
the fight kept me on my toes and I was
excited to see what they threw at me
next
probably one of the biggest changes to
the combat are the new mutations this
adds another level to the progression
system a new mutagen skill tree lets you
unlock a dozen or so new skills perks
and abilities only one of these powerful
skills can be equipped at a time but
some appeared to have dramatic effects
one skill that I got to see was a
variation on art that increased its area
of effect and froze any enemies caught
in the blast these new skills could
allow for even more experimentation and
get even experienced players something
new and worthwhile to grind from what I
played at blood and wine seems like an
excellent send-off to a series I've
become so attached to but what about the
characters my favorite part of The
Witcher series has always been the
characters and I was a little
disappointed when I found out that ciri
Tris and yen did not play much of a role
in the last expansion I'm a little
worried that we may not see some of our
friends and allies that we've spent so
much time with but this is CD Projekt
RED we're talking about and letting down
their fans isn't something they
typically do
I can't wait to see who Geralt will meet
what he will fight and where this
adventure will take him